i'm gonna do a slightly abbreviated
version of this talk
um this is called how to be fast a look
at high performance websites this talk
was supposed to happen yesterday but i
don't know if y'all remember there was a
bit of an evacuation situation and so
this is
when we got rescheduled for so
my name is eric brandis and i build
software that monitors other software so
the main product that we've made my
business partners and i over the years
is track js which is a javascript error
monitoring tool but our javascript error
monitoring customers kept saying hey we
want to know our performance metrics too
right we want to know not only do we
have javascript errors
but
is our website fast and we didn't have a
good way to answer that question for
them and so we built a second product
called request metrics and so my head
has been in the web performance space
for the last two years what we've been
building it and so
this talk is all about ways to go faster
how to measure speed and how you can
make your website faster
um why do we care about speed so
just yesterday i was telling somebody
about this talk and he said that where
he works they don't care about speed
because the users of their software are
paid to use the software and so it's
like we don't care
and i was like well but i feel like as
professionals we should probably
probably have a little pride in our work
and if that doesn't sell you
years and years ago amazon did a bunch
of investigation to performance and they
found that for every 100 milliseconds
that the site was slow
it cost them one percent of their sales
and in fact walmart
just saw the exact same thing a few
years ago
the bbc they noticed that for every
additional second the page took to load
ten percent of the users leave
and google is on the same
track as well so if your page load goes
from one second to three seconds the
probability that the user bounces goes
up thirty two percent
but if it goes from one second to six
seconds the probability of a bounce is
106 percent so users don't like waiting
for slow things
and when we talk about
speed so what does it mean you know what
makes a website fast or slow
we should probably discuss some
terminology
so for years the main barometer of web
performance was load time
and so the load event is fired at a
certain point in the page life cycle
when all of the dependent resources are
done and so when we talk about
performance a lot of what we're talking
about is load time and so if you've ever
looked at the chrome developer tools on
the network tab at the bottom
it will tell you the load time for the
website that you just loaded it will
also give you dom content loaded which
is when the dom is parsed and in memory
but not all of the dependent resources
have been downloaded so both are
interesting numbers but really load
is historically the thing we care about
however google recently has created a
new thing called the core web vitals and
i'm not even going to read that
paragraph to you because so much
marketing speak i can't even stand it
but there are three core web vitals
largest contentful paint
first input delay and cumulative layout
shift now these measure different parts
of page and website performance the
thing that we mainly care about today is
largest contentful paint and we're going
to talk more about what that is in a
second but there is also
a fourth web vital it's not a core web
vital there's only three of those but
one of the other web vitals is first
contentful paint which is related
so if we use bbc.com is an example
if we go to webpagetest.org right they
do a really cool thing where you can put
the website in and it'll show you a
series of thumbnails as it's loading and
they will actually call out first
contentful paint and largest contentful
paint for you and first contentful paint
is when the very first thing whether
it's a text or image or whatever is
rendered on the screen and the idea with
that is you know you want that to be as
fast as possible so the user can tell
that something is happening
largest contentful paint
is the paint that is the biggest area of
the screen
prior to load so here we can see in the
bbc example that that big hero image is
the largest contentful paint the biggest
paint that happens before load
and the idea with largest contentful
paint is that the faster that is the
more likely that your website at least
looks usable to the end user so google
says it should be less than two and a
half seconds which
if you've used modern websites not many
people are doing it under two and a half
seconds
and google is serious about this stuff
so in 2010 they started using load
performance as a signal in search result
rankings for desktop websites
in 2018 they added mobile performance as
a search result ranking factor and as of
2020 the core web vitals are now
actually included
as a ranking factor for your search
results now they're kg they don't say
how much of a factor it is they just say
that they're going to continue to use it
as a factor
but it's important to know about these
core web vitals and measure them so that
you can make sure you're not going to
you know run a follow of google big g
we talk about web performance there are
three big factors outside of your
control the first is what device your
user is using so some people have super
modern smartphones or apple m1 pros and
they're awesome
and some people have eight-year-old
android 4 phones right and that is going
to make a big difference in how they
experience your website
it's also a matter of the connection so
if you're on like a super hardwired
fiber to the home connection your
internet experience is going to be a lot
better than somebody that's on you know
dial up or on the tube and it's like
getting the most body internet ever
and the third thing that we can't really
control for is where the user is coming
from so we don't know how far away they
are from our servers but the further
away they are
the worse the experience is going to be
for them
so
in order to fix and mitigate those three
factors we need to measure performance
first so that we know how are we doing
today
and then we need to speed things up and
so we can measure if we've actually
improved things
so
in the school of web performance
measurement there's two thoughts
you'll hear a lot of people talk about
lab measurement or synthetic measurement
and i call these theoretical
measurements because they are totally
bogus
and the biggest purveyor of nonsense
performance audit data is lighthouse and
so this is a tool that was uh created by
google of course
like 30 of the stuff in this talk was
created by google
um and i call it the thing that everyone
uses for made up results so if you've
never used lighthouse you can find it in
your chrome developer tools right it
lives right here
and it lets you run performance audits
on the site that you're currently
visiting and
you can see you get some categories that
you can choose from
one thing that most people don't know
because this is actually hidden most of
the time you actually have to open this
menu by default lighthouse uses what's
called simulated throttling where they
do some sort of black box network
throttling to try and appear like a real
user would but what does that
mean
now you can uncheck this and they won't
do that but
regardless if you pick mobile they're
going to do more emulation to try and
emulate a mobile device and that
includes things like throttling
and trying to sort of mimic the user age
and other things it's not always perfect
so
for example
here is google.com search results for
web performance
now i don't need a website or lighthouse
or anything to tell me that google
search results are fast every time i
search and hit go it feels practically
instant right
so what does lighthouse google's own
tool say about google.com
they get a 66 on the performance score
with a big orange color which means it's
not very good right
now these scores are
they you know they're out of a hundred
what does it actually mean
you know they've got this rubric for
calculating them
but the big thing that i found really
ironic deeply ironic
was that their seo score is so bad right
this is the company that writes the book
on search engines and they can't
optimize it maybe they don't have to
and you can see their largest contentful
paint and you can start seeing some of
these web vitals in these lighthouse
audits their largest contentful paint is
2.9 seconds
well remember i just told you that
google themselves says you should have
the largest contentful paint less than
two and a half seconds so they don't
even pull it off right
so then i was like well okay maybe this
is just you know i need something to
compare it to right i don't know what a
66 means as far as performance great so
it's orange and that's not very good
so i was like well what is like a really
dog slow site that i can run lighthouse
on what's the worst site i can think of
and i was paying my credit card bill at
the time and so i was like yeah chase
chase.com
this is one of the worst websites on
earth
and when you load chase.com it's so bad
that there's so many loading spinners
this is just three or seven seven
loading spinners that spin when you load
it and i'm like surely this will get
worse than a 66 performance score
so i ran lighthouse against it and it
gets an 80 which is unbelievable
and they nailed the seo game right i
mean google can't do it but chase.com
can with all those loading spinners are
you kidding me
and then you can see the largest
contentful paint is three times faster
than google's in lighthouse
and
i don't think that's right because every
time i use that site it's terribly
painful
so
the whole point of this is just say that
it's not always accurate and to prove it
there's a second kind of measurement
it's called field measurement it's
actually getting the values from the
user's browser when they load a page
and of course google also has that data
so i don't know if you all know but
chrome is sending
statistics for your page loads back to
google and they call it the chrome user
experience report and so chrome is
sending back all of this performance
metric data and you can put in a web
page url into their page speed insights
ui and it will give you back a
performance audit report that looks a
lot like lighthouse
but it's actually using real data so
let's look and see how things go
so here is the chrome user experience
report for google search results for
that query
you can see that they've passed their
web vitals assessment their first
contentful paint is blazing fast and
their largest contentful paint is three
times faster in real life than
lighthouse said it was
and if we go to chase the world's worst
website
they fail their core web vitals
assessment the first contentful paint is
in the orange and their largest contempo
paint is in the orange and it is three
times slower in real life
than it is
in lighthouse so the main point here is
that those synthetic measurements they
might be useful for certain class of
investigation but in my opinion the best
way to measure web performance is get
the data from real users
and so you'll hear you'll hear the term
real user monitoring thrown around a lot
that is often a performance monitoring
plus sort of activity monitoring
tracking clicks and that kind of thing
um so in this case i'm talking about
real user
metrics and we can get all of the
metrics we'd ever want from the browser
itself so all modern browsers including
some older versions of safari support
the window.performance api and so here's
just like a quick little throwaway
one-liner to get the navigation entry
uh for whatever page i think that was
bbc.com
but you can see here the duration is
actually that is the the value of page
load right so you can do this in any
browser right now you can put that in
and you'll actually get
all this detailed information i mean to
like how many decimal points is that
um of how long did load take you can
figure out how long did ssl take you can
figure out what kind of protocol were we
running was http 1 or http2
and so we took all this uh
data that was you know it's just sitting
there waiting for us and so what request
metrics does is it actually just
packages it all up right and sends it
and makes pretty graphs and so the goal
is to show you what is not only your
50th or median percentile right but what
is your 75th percentile and 95
percentile for load because it's in
those margins where your users are going
to start to see poor experience
and we can also use the browser to give
us web vitals data so there is now a
performance observer object that you can
use in chrome
and firefox mostly in a little bit of
safari so the browser support is not as
good
but you can get largest contentful paint
you can get cumulative layout shift you
can get all of the core web vitals from
this at least in chrome for sure
and so we send those to our service too
because what we want to see is how are
we doing on this stuff right like this
data is only interesting in aggregate
right like one person might have a bad
experience
but how about 100 people right
so now that we've talked about all this
like terminology and stuff what are some
tricks that we can use that like the big
guys use like google to be fast right
and so some of this stuff is uh you're
gonna be like yeah this is like brain
dead common sense eric and i know that
but i still see a lot of people not
doing it
so the first thing that we can do to go
faster is just do less right just make
less requests so even google itself
loads something like 39 assets when you
go to the search result page
but you know who doesn't load a lot of
things
gov.uk so i was not planning to include
gov uk in my talk until i came to this
website from my house in minnesota usa
and i was like this is the most fast
website i have ever seen in my life and
i was like what are they doing like it's
a really simple site i know it's a lot
of text it's pretty basic functionality
so it should be fast but it is really
fast
and i'm looking and they they only lose
17 things which is crazy like
that is the lowest i've seen on any
major like public facing website it's
only 200 kilobytes over the wire
and you can just see that like load is
is blinding fast 220 milliseconds is
crazy and that's from my house
in the us so we're gonna talk about that
more later
and i was also like man every time i go
back to the website it's really fast and
so one of the things that i see people
screw up all the time
is caching right so if we look so i load
i loaded gov.uk for the second time
because i wanted to see how they did on
caching and you can see that literally
every one of the static content assets
came from the cache right so hurrah
they've got it configured right
but what's more interesting and i don't
see this hardly ever but this is cool
and you all should think about it
i went to
www.gov.uk and you can see here that my
browser only got 81 bytes back from the
server it knows that the html is 82 kb
right but it only got 81 bytes back and
that's because
they have their etags configured
correctly and we got a 304 back
instead of a 200 with all that content
because when we made that request
my browser sent an if-none match header
with the e-tag that it retrieved last
time and as long as it didn't change
it'll send a 304 back and it'll just
pull it from disk cache right
so
i rarely see this in the wild and it's
great
and of course the people who built this
site they did it all for the static
content as well
so there's a couple things i want to
call out just in terms of getting your
cache control stuff right there's sort
of two two pieces of the puzzle the
first is you need to use the right cache
control header
in this case they've got a huge max age
so max age is measured in seconds right
and they've got i don't know what that
is it's like 15 years or something
and they've also marked it as public
which means that downstream proxies and
caches can cache it and they've also
marked it as immutable and i don't see
too many people using the immutable
keyword but it is really nice it's a
little bit newer and it just tells the
browser as well as downstream caches
that like this thing will never change
like if there's a new version it'll have
a new file name right you can safely
conclude that this will never ever ever
change
and they also put a far futures expire
header on it right so that's 15 years
too i think right december 2037.
so those two things mean that my browser
as long as the cache you know exists on
disk as long as i haven't cleared it
it will never go back
over the wire for these assets and when
they change they'll just update it looks
like they got commit hashes or some kind
of file hash in the name whenever the
file changes they'll just change the
file name right so this is easy stuff
but a lot of people don't do it
same thing with smaller files right so i
say compress everything everybody knows
that right
except for
like i've got this javascript here i
know it's tiny the point is not to read
it the point is i'm gonna put it in
a minifier so if we uglify.js it we
actually take that little bit of
javascript and it goes down 66 from
minification
and i would say broadly we see about a
60 to 70
size reduction in minification in
general and you're all saying yeah yeah
we minify we minified
except
a lot of times i see people are running
webpack builds and they forget to put it
in production mode right so they're
actually sending out inline source maps
and all sorts of just terrible stuff to
their production website so it's one of
those things like just make sure you
check the box
and then if we look at our friend google
here so i was curious what does google
do as far as compression goes right and
i kind of knew the answer but i wanted
to check
so when my browser firefox in this case
because i wanted to see if it was
supported
made a request to google it said hey
i'll accept these three different kinds
of content encodings right you've
probably seen gzip and deflate before
and if you're in the web space you've
probably heard of broadly or br
right and sure enough
they gave me back bradley right
and so does gov.uk for example
and so i didn't actually know what a
broadly was i'd heard of this for years
but i didn't actually know what it was
named after it turns out it's a swiss
pastry
of some kind that's what google image
search comes up so i don't know if
that's right but that's what they said
and the reason you might consider
broadly instead of gzip is because it
does on average gives you about a 20
size reduction in html
and it's about the same cpu time as gzip
depending on settings right so you're
basically paying the same cost but
getting a slightly better compression
ratio so bradley is the thing that if
it's easy if you can just change it in
your framework might be worth it or on
your web server
so if we look at compression in real
life so we have to do this for request
metrics the product i built so we have a
javascript agent that we have customers
put on their websites to get all of that
metric data
the original size of that javascript
file it's like a big webpack typescript
thing
it's 46 kb once we minify it it goes
down to 16 kb or 65 savings once we
g-zip it we save a further 10 kilobytes
and so we've actually saved 83
of the bytes over the wire i also tried
it with bradley just to see and you get
about a six percent improvement over
gzip which in our case is probably not
worth it right i think um i think
there's other things we could do
probably if we cared but just you know
frame of reference
one last thing i bet especially in
microsoft world you're probably not
doing is compressing your json api
responses so for years asp.net mvc and
mvc core did not automatically turn on
gzip compression
for json responses
you can but it just wasn't on by default
i don't know what the default is today
but it'd be worth checking because json
is eminently compressible right and so
you could get a lot of um performance
savings just by turning that on
especially if you're doing single page
applications where there's a lot of api
calls or if you're using something like
graphql or whatever
so let's talk about images for a second
so images the general rule of thumb is
you can't compress images right they're
already compressed the whole point of
the image codec is to take like make the
smallest possible binary representation
this image
but that's not quite true if you've
never used tiny png you should try it so
if you have a png image and feed it to
tiny png they will give you back a png
that's even smaller but looks identical
and supposedly it works with webp and
jpeg too i haven't tried it with those
but there is a visual studio code
extension where you just right click on
the image and say send to tiny png and
it will just come back fully compressed
so it's pretty easy to do and they have
you know full cli and api integration
too
and if you haven't seen webp before
google loves using webp because they
invented it and um it's cool though
because it is 26 percent smaller than
png's and it does support some things
that pngs don't like animation right so
it's kind of meant to be a replacement
for animated gifs
and pngs and it supports alpha
transparency so it can do a lot of
things
google almost exclusively serves webp
to modern browsers
the problem with webp
is that it's not fully supported
everywhere so firefox google and new
safari all supported just fine but there
are some old laggards where
older safaris will show static images
but they will not show the animated ones
ie doesn't support it at all i don't
know how many people still support ie
but
the other thing that you can do as far
as images go is you can send different
sized images to different devices
depending on aspect ratio um
with viewport width or resolution so
back to google if we look at their logo
right and if we expand this out
they've got the usual image stuff right
they've got a source but they've got a
new attribute called source set right
it's new it's been around for a few
years but it's pretty widely supported
now
and you can see here they've actually
specified two images one with one x or
sort of normal resolution one with two x
or high dpi
like retina style right
and so
i was requesting with my crappy windows
desktop and i got the 1x version because
it is not high dpi which saved me a
bunch of bytes over the wire so if you
do have an image heavy site it might be
worth considering using source set and
sending smaller images
you can also instead of 1x or 2x you can
put in widths so like if the viewport
width of the device is 480 or less send
on this small image versus you know the
full desktop image and that is a great
way it's a little bit work but it's a
great way to lower the amount of bites
over the wire
and the last image trick is google does
this a lot i don't see it very often
anywhere else but if
if you have small images like these so
when i search for web performance these
three images came up if we look at this
image and inspect it in the browser
right we'll find out it's not actually
living on a server somewhere they sent
me
base64 encoded data right they're using
a data url so there was no request made
to get this image they included the
entire binary source of the image
in the response from their server
now you can see the file size is only
4.5 kb
and they only do it for small images
especially when they have a lot of
little small images and the reason is
because anytime you base 64 something
you're going to increase its size by 33
so
as things get bigger
you're not going to want to pay that 33
increase you'd rather just make another
request for it right
okay so now i want to talk about
proximity and things you can do to
mitigate people that are far away
so the way that request metrics works
today right when someone goes to visit
our app or sends data to us
if there's two servers that live in
montreal canada so no matter where you
are in the world
you are talking to a server in canada
right so from the uk it's going to be
slower than from somebody in you know
toronto or whatever
so like wouldn't it be cool
if we could have multiple
locations right and obviously you can so
i'll get there but the nice thing about
multiple locations is then your users
don't have to go as far
and so one way to do that like the best
way like the way where you have full
control but it's also the most
complicated is called geodns right
that's what google uses we're going to
look at in a second
but geodns takes into account the
requester's ip so when i ask for
google.com it says where are you
requesting from oh minnesota i'm going
to give you the server closest to
minnesota or if i'm in london it'll say
oh
here's the london ip right
and so they actually have full control
over which ips get returned
so if we look at it
right so if i run ns lookup from my
machine in minnesota usa google lives at
this ip address
if i plug that ip address into a reverse
ip lookup i find out it's in chicago
it's 400 miles away from my house is
where google lives for me
the speed of light can do 400 miles in
2.1 milliseconds
how long do you think it takes to do a
ping
right so just as a quick aside a ping is
a single
a single packet going over the wire and
coming back right so it's only 32 bytes
and it doesn't even use tcp or anything
it uses icmp so it's quite lightweight
protocol
it's about as fast as you can get
so for my house in minnesota to talk to
google in chicago it takes 26 ish
milliseconds right that's pretty good
but it's still 10 times slower than the
speed of light and i thought we were
supposed to move at the speed of light
right we've got fiber and all this stuff
well the reason is because there's 12
hops between my house and 400 miles away
in chicago right so each one of those
routers
um is adding a little bit of latency
and so when we look at loading google we
can see it's 45 milliseconds to do the
ssl handshake which isn't too bad we're
not waiting for very long
content downloads half a second the
whole thing is done in 750 milliseconds
right that's pretty good
so then i set up a computer in london i
was like well how long you know like if
i'm in london
and i say where is google what does it
give me back right well it gives me back
a different ip address
so i looked up this ip address and this
ip address is right in the heart of the
city like city of london and so google
of course has servers everywhere
so when i ping it look at the ping on
this guy so from my machine in london
which is in the digital ocean data
center
to google it's only like two
milliseconds like those machines have to
be
very close to each other
so then i got to thinking well how much
does proximity actually matter what if i
take that ip address right i take the ip
address
that's in the city of london what if i
take that and make that like my hosts
file for google.com right so that like
from my house in minnesota i'm actually
talking to google servers in london
how long how big of a distance is it and
how long does it take
so it's about 10 times
greater physical distance as the crow
flies so it's about 4 000 miles
the speed of light can do that in 21
milliseconds
what do you think the ping is going to
be for this one it's not as bad as you
think actually it's like 105
milliseconds so it's it's five times
slower
not ten times slower you know what i
mean like you might expect
and the reason is
there's more hops there's 12 hops to
chicago there's 18 to london so there's
not 10 times more hops there's only 50
percent more hops actually and so one of
those hops is a big long fiber cable
across the atlantic and so you really
don't take as bad of a hit as you think
but a five-time slowdown is still
significant
we can see that the tls uh ssl
negotiation takes three times longer
um two times longer getting the data
back time to first byte from the server
and we see the content download actually
managed to do it in a pretty respectable
1.6 times slower and we average out
about 1.8 times so on the one hand
that's not too bad right on the one hand
like two times slower to go 4000 miles
like that's
not the worst
the problem is this is just for getting
the html from google.com
every other resource is going to be
subject to the same performance slowdown
and those things are going to add up
when you've got 20 or 30 or 40 resources
right and all of a sudden that two-time
slowdown starts to be a four or five or
six times slow down and we do care about
that
so geodns is hard to pull off geodns is
hard because we most of us don't have
global databases that span the whole
world like google does right we have a
database that lives one place and so no
matter how many other places we try and
you know
put servers we still have a single point
of truth generally
so this is where anycast can come in and
so i don't know if you all have heard of
any cast before but what it means is
that multiple servers separated around
the world
all have the same ip address
right
so let me give you an example so i was
really surprised that gov.uk was so fast
from my house in minnesota and i was
like how can that be so i decided to
look it up i said where is gov uk and i
did this from my machine in london and i
did it for my machine in the usa
and i got back the same ip addresses
so the gov.uk site existed those four
ips
but then i pinged it i was like well
i'll take the same ip and i'll ping it
and when i ping it
it's 24 milliseconds from my house in
the u.s and it's you know two
milliseconds from the uk
to the same ip
well that's because they're using
anycast and specifically those ips are
actually fastly so that is fastly ips
they're using them as their content
delivery network
um the last point here is
it's worth considering a cdn if you have
a lot of static content that doesn't
change very often um or even if it does
because not because the cdn's more
reliable not because their network is
better per se but because they're closer
hopefully to your end user right and
that does start to add up especially the
more requests that you're making
now you get to talk about protocols so
have you guys heard of quick before so
this is another google thing goodness
it's actually called http 3 now so
google developed this thing called quick
it was a new http like protocol and they
liked it so much that eventually they
started standard track 4 and now it's
http 3. and so you can see that when i
go to google.com i'm actually using http
3 to talk to all of their servers
and you might be saying wait a minute
what happened to http 2 didn't we just
convert everything to htmp2 like didn't
microsoft just finally start supporting
it in windows server 2020 and of course
you're right
if you look gov uk is still using http
2.
right and netflix is still using http1
so i do want to just talk about the
differences between the protocols real
quick so you can understand why maybe
you'd want to use two or maybe you'd
want to use three if it's available
back in the http days it was one
connection
one request per resource right you want
javascript you got three files three
requests
you could keep persistent connections
open but it would take server-side
resources as well
now to get around this problem browsers
would open six parallel requests per
domain
so clever people back in the day and i
remember doing this myself
would actually create multiple domains
that all point to the same standard
content servers so the browser would
parallelize more requests right it was
called domain sharding if you remember
and really the problem that they're
trying to talk about or get around is
what's called head of line blocking
and it's basically all it means is that
if you've got three images
the first one
is gonna block everybody else behind it
right so if i go get image one i have to
wait for him to come back before i can
go get image two
i have to wait for that one to come back
before i go get image three right and so
then the smart people they made the
parallel requests so if i've got nine
images right
i'll send six requests off and as they
come back i'll start making more
requests
so that didn't really scale and so for
http 2 the big change was that they no
longer do multiple connections you can
now request multiple files over a single
tcp stream so that's the big difference
in theory it solves the head of line
blocking problem i can in one tcp stream
i can ask for 20 things and i'll get 20
things back in the response right
the problem is it does fix head of line
blocking at the hcp level
but it doesn't fix it at the tcp level
and what i mean is so this is kind of
conceptually what's happening right
you're asking for everything all at once
and you're getting everything back all
at once
but actually under the covers what it's
doing is interleaving all of the bytes
for all the different files
so if you've got five images coming back
but say something happens say you've got
to do a tcp retransmit for some reason
right a packet got lost
everything is still blocked because
you're waiting for all those pieces to
get back and because of tcp itself
you've still got this head of line
blocking issue though it is much better
let's see how much better so here's
amazon.com right and they load 330
requests 330 things come down to draw
that page which is absolutely astounding
so i loaded it 20 times each with http 1
and then 20 times each with http 2
enabled in my browser
so you can see for http 1 the 95th
percentile actually gets pretty bad
right you start to see some long tail
things every once in a while and median
75th are okay
but we really start to see improvement
which are on http 2 right everything
gets a little bit closer together all
the timings are more consistent
and because they're loading so many
resources if we look
the average image takes about one second
to come from amazon.com
in http1 land
but at hp2
it's only 312 milliseconds we saved it's
a 3x speed up on images just to enable
http 2 right
enter http 3. so now the deal with http
3 is it's not even using tcp right they
figured out okay that was dumb like
we'll do something different so now what
they do is they make a tcp like protocol
over udp and everybody gets their own
udp data stream so that if even one of
them has a problem in packet loss the
other ones don't block so that's kind of
the big thing
can you use http 3
uh maybe if you're google yes if you're
anybody in the microsoft landscape no
um
caddy has full support for it nginx is
working seriously on official support
there is a beta that you can download
and we'll turn on http 3.
and um if you're on iis well i hope
you're on windows server 2022
which i didn't even know that was a
thing
that will supposedly enable it
as far as http 3 goes it came with
another sort of trick though
it came with tls 1.3
so um
in tls 1.2 to do an ssl handshake you
have to do two full round trips
in tls 1.3 they got down to one round
trip they can do one round trip to do
the whole ssl negotiation so right there
you're saving quite a bit of time
but it gets better tls13 introduced
what's called zero round trip connection
negotiation so after the first time you
talk to your server they actually
pre-share the keys so the next time it
talks it doesn't have to do any
negotiation it can just start making
requests and so that can make a really
big difference
current support varies but it's better
than http 3. you can start using it even
with http 2. it's supported widely by
most web servers except for
iis so
still be waiting for that um couple
quick things zero rtt is not enabled by
default because there are some security
concerns with it i think they're a
little overblown but you do have to
enable it if you want to
and they've dramatically cleaned up the
number of cipher suites that you would
use it used to be i don't know if you
guys ever looked at like the amount of
supported ciphers but it was like this
huge list of just like wildly named
things
now there's only three three that you
have to implement
and so the last way to speed things up
that i want to talk about and then we'll
go drink some more beer
is if you don't need something right
away
load it later right because when we
talked about load time load was fired
after all the dependent resources
finished downloading
well what if it wasn't a dependent
resource what if you said hey don't
worry about it right i and gov.uk does
this really well
i'm going to use the async attribute
right i'm going to load all my scripts
async and they're not going to delay
page load at that point the browser is
not going to wait for them to come back
before it loads so you've got to make
sure your code can actually support that
but it's a great way if you want to to
do things later and get your load time a
little bit faster if there are things
that you can wait for
and the other thing that you can do if
you have an image heavy site the bbc
does this pretty well
is um they lazy load images so as you're
scrolling
um
they don't actually you don't pay to
download that image
until you actually put it in the
viewport now they have a complicated
javascript mechanism that they're using
for this but in 2022 for the most part
we can actually use the loading equals
lazy attribute which is super cool and
so it just lets the browser say well
once it's in the viewport then i'll go
get it right it's fairly widely
supported and so if you weren't doing
anything about lazy loading before it's
an easy way to get started because
old browsers just ignore it
okay so the last thing to wrap it up
there's a lot of ways there's a million
knobs that you can turn to go faster
right
but in order to know if you're being
successful you have to measure it first
right and then you have to figure out
what works for your app because not all
of these make sense in all use cases
right and there's no silver bullet
i would say the most important thing is
do the fundamentals everyone knows them
but nobody doesn't it's like flossing
twice a day or whatever it's like yeah i
know i should do that but it sucks
but it's worth it
and i would say that if you have a
technique that supports it one of the
more modern protocols would be
beneficial http 2 for sure
and if you can htv 3 and tls 13 are an
easy way to get more performance without
actually having to make any changes to
your application code
and finally it's good idea to get closer
to the user if you can so if you can put
your static content on a cdn with many
points of presence around the globe and
it's not too cumbersome from a
deployment perspective
it might be worth it
and finally in terms of measuring i
would say that it's really only used
like worth it to consider field metrics
or real metrics obtained from your users
right because if all of your users
are experiencing your website well who
cares what lighthouse thinks right if
everybody's having a great experience fu
lighthouse
that's it let's go drink some beers